NumPy also offers several function to
create empty arrays with initial values.
For certain computations these help
avoid growing arrays incrementally
which can be an expensive operation.
Let's start with
creating an empty array.
The empty function takes
the shape of the array as input.
The shape can be defined as a single
integer, as we did over here, for
creating a one dimensional array, or
a sequence of integers denoting
the size in each dimension.
For a two dimensional array,
a sequence of two integers is needed.
That is the number of rows and
the number of columns.
For this example, we will create
an empty array with five rows and
four columns.
Passing in a tuple with values 5 and 4.
So here I pass a tuple with values 5 and
4.
In case you need a three
dimensional array, or any
greater number of dimensions, you can
just add another number to the sequence.
This will give you a 3 dimensional
array with a depth of 3, and
each depth having 5 rows and 4 columns.
For this lesson we will only work
with two dimensional arrays.
Now let's check the output.
Hm, strange.
The empty array is not actually empty.
What happens is that when we call
numpy.empty to create an array,
the elements of the array
read in whatever
values were present in
the corresponding memory location.
These are effectively
random values that depend
on the state of the computer's memory.
Also observe that by default
the elements are the floating points.
Next we create an array full of ones.
Like the empty function,
we pass in the number of rows and
columns as a sequence.
To create an array full of ones,
you call the one function and
pass the sequence, which has number
of rows and number of columns.
You can expect this time to
have an array of 5 rows and
4 columns with all
the values equal to 1.
Let's go ahead and check this.
Here it is.
An array with 5 rows, 4 columns, and
all the values of the array equal to 1.